Tyler: Dad, Catch!
Mark: *laughs* Go long, son.
*Jogs away*
Tyler: Is this far enough?!
Mark: A little more!
Tyler: Okay!
Mark: Oh! Oh!
Tyler: I'm open!
Mark: Just a little more. I got a good arm.
Tyler: Aaaawwww
Mark: Little more. Little more.
Tyler: Throw it! Throw it!
Mark: Little farther!
Tyler: How 'bout now?!
Mark: C'mon, more!
Tyler: How about now?!
Mark: Little more!
Tyler: I'm open!
Mark: (whispers) Just a little more.
Tyler: Throw it!
*Nice music*
*Mark flees in terror from his responsibilities*
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome
to Madden 17!
Where we're gonna be playing
and re-.. we're gonna be... we're gonna be PRE-ENACTING
It's not a reenactment if it's before it happens. *Tyler laughing*
We're gonna be PRE-ENACTING the Super Bowl
L.I.
L.I.?
Is that it?
It's the Super Bowl!
And apparently we're not allowed to say the word Super Bowl,
so here comes
Markiplier's Super Bowl Spectacular Super
uhhh
Mega Bowl, Bowl haircut
Super Super Cuts
*whisper* Fuck
Uhhh.. Blayuhhhugh *laughing by Tyler*
Okay, so, one thing that you need to know to preface this,
and a lot of you may care about this, a lot of you may not.
He *points at Tyler*
LOVES Tom Brady
Tyler: NO I DON'T!(Both laugh) NO I DON'T!
Okay, he doesn't like Tom Brady for whatever reason, I dunno why.
And, um, supposedly, Tom Brady "CHEATED," or something.
He was TOO good, is--I-I think what happened there.
So, y'know, he-he really, uh..I dunno.
Tyler's got a stick up his butt for Tom Brady, so.
Tyler: So for the sake of... pestering me, he's making me play as the Patriots.
Mark: I'm "MAKING" you?
Yeah, I'm making you.*Mark laughs*
Tyler: So, I'm-I'm conflicted cause I want to win, (Mark: Yeah.) but I don't want the Patriots to win the Super Bowl.
Mark: Yeah, and this determines it! If we-if-if he wins with the Patriots,
which is likely, considering I have NO goddamn idea how to play.
Tyler: HOOO!
Mark: Oh, that's my jam!
Tyler: Oh, that's insane!
Mark: Oh, that's my jam.
Ready to go down?!
Tyler: N--Yes! No?!
Mark: Yeah, we got--like, the UFC fighting pose.
*Extreme squinting and jaw clenching.*
Together: Spoon!
Mark: Okay
So welcome to the Super Bowl with the Atlanta Falcons and the Patriots.
Tyler: The--The cheating Patriots
Mark: The cheating Patriots that Tyler is gonna play as.
The Man, (Tyler:I) the Myth, the Legend
Tom Brady, himself!
Tyler: NO! NO! *Mark laughs at Tyler*
Mark: If you're Tom Brady, you need to live as Tom Brady
You're not a "redeemed" Tom Brady
You're Tom Brady that wants to-
Tyler: That was suspended for two games *Tyler laughs*
Mark: Two whole games
Tyler: At the beginning of this season.
Mark: Oh you're doing that ok
Tyler: Huuahh! Oh--Oh?
Mark: So--So
We have a basic understanding of how this goes.
Ha!!
Mark: Ahhhhhhhhh
Tyler: Go, go,
Mark: Oh! Beware my big dick!
Tyler: Go, go, ahhhh got you!
Mark: Oh fuck.
Tyler: Big hug!
Mark: Big hug? (both laughing)
Mark: Big hug. Ha
Tyler: Did you see his arms?
Mark: Yeah!
Tyler: They were just all over like
Together: Ahhhhhh
Mark: I--I-- My jukes didn't work
I forgot that you had to press a button to juke
Tyler: Oh, you were just, like
Mark: and not just like
Tyler: Owaaahhh
Mark: I was just trying to make the blue line
You know, like, *gently* where am I going? What am I doing?
Oh, wait! Yeah, let me, like, turn off that damn narration.
I've gotta do a Hail Mary *giggles*
I think it's the best way to start off a Super Bowl is with a Hail Mary
Tyler: You're ditching the game plan!
Mark: *coughs* *giggles*
That's pretty--pretty accurate there.
*gasps* oh-oh-oh-oh-ah-eh
Not gonna get me!
Mark: (Arnold Schwarzenegger noise)
Tyler: Oh!
Mark: Gonna be aggressive!
Tyler: Oh! I got it!
Mark: Ohhh! I almost had that!
Tyler: Oh!!!
Tyler: If you would've caught that. Oh!.
Mark: Oh no!
Mark: Can I do nothing but Hail Marys?
Tyler: You could, that's not a-- I mean, that's a-- that's a strategy *Mark giggles*
Mark: (giggles) Oh, man.
Tyler: Are you gonna?
Mark: Yeah! Yeah! Of course I am!
Tyler: Oh jeez
Mark: (stammers) and like we said,
this is exactly--EXACTLY-- how the Super Bowl is gonna go
Mark: Ouuughh
SANSU'S GOT IT!
Mark: Uh oh.
Tyler: Oh Oh! It's mine! It's mine!
Mark: NO!
Tyler: YES! YES! *muffled by Mark's despair*
Mark: NOOOOOO!! NOOOOOOOOO!!
Tyler: Woh-
Mark: I got you! Oh fuck.
Tyler: Woo!
Mark: I got you!
Tyler: Whheeeewww! *celebratory dancing*
Mark: Hey.
Tyler: Wait.
Mark: *Strange voice* Let's pull a Mulligan on this one.
Tyler: *STRONG DISAGREEANCE* NOOOOO *wheeze*
Mark: Lets just... you know.... it's- we're all friends here, TOM BRADY.
Tyler: No! I mean- NO!
Tyler: Not Tom Brady!
Mark: *mischevious giggling*
Tyler: Wait, I am for- oh no.
Mark: Yeah,
Mark: You know,  I don't think... I stand a chance against the man with the golden arm,
the man who has rockets for legs.
Tyler: The man with the deflation-needle
Mark: Fetish.
Tyler: *wheeze* is that a- deflation.
Mark: *Giggle*
Mark: Uh, inflation fetish is a thing,
but therefore deflation fetish must be a thing.
Mark: Free Fire... Shoot 'em. That's how we should do this.
Tyler: Freedom!
Mark: Shoot 'em.
Mark: Yeah.. that sounds good.
Mark: Why are you so close, did you run that far?
Tyler: Yeah!
Mark: WHAT?!
Mark: I Hailed Mary'd that.
Mark: Euuuhhhhhh uhuu
Tyler: *Very unenthusiastic "hoo"*
Mark: A misdirection..
Tyler: A BELLY.
Mark: A belly?
Tyler: I'm gonna counter you with a belly!
Mark: Not my belly!
Tyler: It's the belly counter
Mark: How could you do that,
Mark: my sensitive underbelly.
Tyler: Is there an outer-belly to you?
Mark: Oh, HELL there's an outerbelly.
Tyler: Huuaah!
Mark:EEHHHG
*In a beautiful chorus*
Tyler: Ouuaahhhhhh!
Mark: Nooooooooooooo!!
Mark: Euuhhhhh
Mark: It's just- that- These ragdolls suck.
*Suggestive moan*
Mark: It's like, you know, glue.
*makes "sticking" noises and sticks and goes down with Tyler*
Mark: I got you
*both laugh*
Mark: You got it. Oh, don't pump me
Tyler: No, I- I'm gonna be an artist in this one.
Mark: Oh okay.
Mark: Just like Tom Brady himself.
Tyler: NO!
Mark: Really, a true artist on the field of football.
Mark: Oh Deisch-outf-ooooeieieoo
Tyler: WHEW!
Mark: I- y- you see-
Tyler: That was- that was a wiggle.
Mark: You see how my guy, he moved out of the way for you.
Tyler: *Laughter*
Mark: Did you like that?
Mark: You gonna score a toochdoon?
Tyler: A toochdoon?
Mark: You gonna sc- you gonna tooch me?
Mark: Tooch me.
Tyler: *whispers* tooch
Mark: Ple-he-he-he-hease
Both: *SUDDEN SCREAMING*
Tyler: Go for it!
Mark: NO!
Mark: I dunno, looks like you're just destroying me.
OH! Maybe not.
Ma-
Tyler: That- that was a- a nice-a hit-a.
Mark: It was ALL ME,  even though I was controlling someone way off in the corner don't mind me.
I keep spamming circle for some reason
Tyler: Auuuhhhhhh I'm gonna spin!
Mark: And it- it just changes my character over and over again. *Both laugh*
Tyler: I don't know if that's a... good strategy or a bad strategy.
Mark: Noooo it's not, obviously it's not.
Tyler: NOPE that's-
Mark: AAAUUUUGGGGHHHH
Tyler: That was- that was you got me in the back...
Mark: (giggles) Thanks man.
Tyler: ...in the back field.
Mark: Oh I got your back.
Mark: Chtya!
Tyler: Do sick curls for ya.
Mark: Haa- oh what am I doing you don't know what the defense is.
Tyler: There's so many blue circles just spinning around.
Mark: I can't see 'em! They're too crazy!
Mark: OH! Just gonna stop ya, just gonna stop ya!
*Screaming*
Mark: Awwwwwwww..
Tyler: TOOCHDOOWWWNNN!
Tyler: Wait, that means Tom Brady scored a touchdown.
Mark: Yeah, exactly.
Mark: You're doing great man.
Tyler: NO!
Mark: Mr. Brady, can I have your autograph?
Tyler: No!
Mark: (evil laugh)
Tyler: (Arnold Schwarzenegger impression) Do you have to go cry.
Mark: What, is that Brady's accent?
Mark: (Scottish Accent) NOH
Tyler: Noh
Mark(The accent continues): I throw real FAAAHHR
Mark:(And again with the accent) I throw ball good.
Tyler: I-
Tyler: (Arnold Schwarzenegger impression) I am famous deflated man *wheeze*
*Both laugh*
Mark: I'm a deflated man.
Mark: Here comes ME.
Mark: *Goofs* I'M ON THE WAY!
Mark: Euugh
Tyler: I did it!
Mark: Good job *laughing*
Tyler: Press- press square
Mark: oh.
Mark: *softly* I don't wanna press square
Tyler: Square.
Tyler: And
Tyler: R1
Mark: OHHHHHHHH that was- that's very helpful to me. *Laughs*
Tyler: I figured I'd make it fair in consideration man
Mark: Thank you! It's like ALL my guys are way the fuck over there.
Mark: IT'S MINE!
Tyler: NO!
Mark: PERFECT!
Tyler: AAH!
Tyler: That wasn't *wheeze* It just said, "PERFECT"
Mark: Did you- did you see how perfect that was?
PERFECT
Mark: (giggling)
Tyler: Was that perfect for my kick or-
Mark: No. Nn- me.Catch. Just this guy.
Mark: It just recognized him the camera caught him and he was so handsome it was like "Oh! Thanks."
*Mark and Tyler giggles*
Mark: So, the thing is like, I've never actually played football,
um, like in school or anything like that like I- I never- WoooOoO ahHH
Tyler: We talked about like.. wishing you had.
Mark: Yeah! I- I really did. I did marching band which is like the same time as football's done,
cause I was always athletic but I was lazy,
Which is weird, cause, like, marching band was not the right choice for laziness.
Tyler: No.
Mark: No.
Mark: God no.
Tyler: That was a lot of work.
Tyler: Y- you guys made us empty the parking lot so you could practice.
Mark: Yeah, yeah, no, that was us.
And we'd practice like 12 hour days and you- you think that with marching band it's like,
"Oh it's just easy bullshit" but like most of the time it's-it's actually legit hard work and, and-
Tyler: Whoa, you tricked me!
Mark: *screams* NOOOOOOOOOOO
Mark: I had my chance!
Tyler: That was a good trick.
Mark: I- I did it on purpose man,
Mark: Just distract him with my- m
Tyler: I was like, oh he's running the ball - wait.
Mark: My marching band tricks.
Mark: Yeah I- I- I know, I know man. Yeah.
marching band really got it
Mark: But-
Tyler: But yeah what position did you think you would play
Mark: Well, I mean, that- that's the thing I never knew
And I mean, you had talked about running back but then- or, no, I'D talked about running back but you said something else.
Mark: Besides running back.
Tyler: Um..
Tyler: I could see you as a running back but I could also see you as like,
a defensive, like, cornerback.
Mark: Ah, okay.
Tyler: Which is the guy who covers the receiver.
Mark: Yeah.
Tyler: So, like,
Not that guy that you just threw at, but the guy that was following your guy.
Mark: Yeah.
Tyler: That's a cornerback.
Mark: See, I don't know, like, I- I- I don't know if I would have ever been good at receiving.
I mean I- I'm fast, or I WAS fast, anyway, who knows what I am now but.
Tyler: He was really fast.
Mark: Yeah.
Tyler: That's a long field goal.
Mark: Good thing I'm going to do a Hail Mary instead. *laughs*
Tyler: Alright, Alright.
Tyler: We're gonna do- I'm gonna- I'm gonna strategize.
Mark: Okay.
Tyler: You ready for this?
Mark: What is that?
Mark: Oh.
Tyler: I'm bringing it all.
Mark: That's a blitz. That's not going to let me Hail Mary, is it?
Mark: I've got like two seconds to do this, don't I?
Mark: Uh oh
Tyler: GOOD LUCK!
Mark: *extreme spittle* GOOD LUCK.
Mark: Yeah, you know what? Don't need luck.
Mark: Cause you know what I got a whole lot of?
Mark: (heavy whispered grunt) testicular power
Mark: OH NO!
Tyler: AHHHHHH!
Mark: YOU DIDN'T WARN ME!
Tyler: I FORGOT! I FORGOT!
Mark: Ohhhhhh
Tyler: I didn't look at it!
Mark: You didn't waarn meee
Tyler: Here. I'll decline it.
Tyler: If it let's me decline it I'll decline it.
Mark: I don't think it will.
Mark: Naaah I deserve that.
Tyler: I can decline it though!
Mark: No it's fine, it's fine, accept it, I get it, it's alright.
Mark: Like,
Tyler: Oh, now it wants you to do-
Mark: No- OH GOD NO I'M PUNTING- AHHHH FUCK
Tyler: I called a time out for you
Mark: Well that's- what's that gonna do?
Tyler: Now you can pick a different punt
Mark: OHHHHH you're right.
Mark: Thank you.
Mark:You're so nice to me, Tom Brady.
Tyler: NOOOOOOOO!
Mark: Tom Brady is a man of the people,
And that should be told as far and wide as possible.
Tyler: Okay, okay, I'll give him the benefit of the doubt,
Tyler: Because,
Tyler: Amy and Katherine lived in Boston. Apparently when the Patriots won and it was "Tom Brady that did it all."
Mark: Yeah.
Tyler: They got- free coffee.
Mark: Oh yeah, that's true.
Tyler: From Dunkin' Donuts.
Mark: Every time quote unquote "Tom Brady"
or the Patriots, I guess, win, Boston gets free Dunkin' for a day or some- one free coffee.
Mark: So that's kinda cool but more cool of Dunkin's than Tom Brady himself.
Mark: Are you ready
Mark: For the THUNDER?!
Mark: Oh god oh god oh god OH GOD rrrraaAAAAA
Tyler: Oh no
Mark: AHHHHHH
Both: Awwwwwww
Tyler: Matt Ryan's arm threw it too far.
Mark: Matt Ryan's got arms like sticks.
Tyler: He's got-
Mark: The thing was, our highschool for football would have been GODawful.
Tyler: OH NO!
Mark: WAAAAAAAHHHHH YOUR SACK!
Mark: Was that your sack?
Tyler: That was Brady's sack.
Mark: Oh!! Brady's.. *Mwah* Sweet godly sack.
Tyler: Thank you for hitting Brady.
*Mark laughs*
Tyler: I appreciate that.
Mark: Oh okay, this is a win-win for you and me.
We've got a big Super Bowl party that we're going to be throwing tomorrow
Mark: We've got a bunch of people coming over-
Tyler: Today
Mark: *realization*
Mark: Right! Today, when you guys see this
Tyler: *laughs*
Mark: Sorry, SUPER BOWL SUNDAY *coughs*
Mark: They saw behind the curtain.
Mark: *falls to floor* I have to DIE
Tyler: Oh NoO
*giggling ensues*
Mark: "Sam Will Blitz." SURE Sam will,
will Sam eat green eggs and ham?
Tyler: Wait- whose Sam?
Mark: what?
Tyler: Which- whose Sam you're talking about?
Mark: I don't know, it just said "Sam Will Blitz."
Tyler: Alright, this is what the play looks like.
Mark: Okay.
Tyler: You ready?
Mark: This is what- I- *stammering*
Mark: Sure- AAHHH fuck.
*Mark screams*
Mark: NO!
Mark: OH!
Mark: WOOOOOOO!
Tyler: NO! AHH!
Mark: YAYYYYY!
Tyler: You took that away from my dude
Mark:YES!
Mark: That's what you get for revealing your strategy.
Mark: I've been practicing this game for hours.
Alright *giggle* Hail Mary
*shouts* Here we go!
Ooh, whoa (Tyler: OOH)
The FU- (Tyler: *shouts* You tricked me!)
I didn't mean to do anything
I'm sorry
Tyler: That was good trickery
I ran.. I was just like
Mark: Again
Tyler: *shouts* I'mma come at you! (Mark: Again)
Again, Mr. Ryan here knows his stuff about trickery
Tyler: I'm ready for
Mark: My, my incre-
Tyler: "Overload Seam"
Mark: *wheezes* overload
Don't overload my seam, bro
Tyler: I'm overloadin *mumbles*
Mark: My pants are strained enough
Mark: at looking at Tom Brady
Tyler: Oh look
Tyler: Oh my guys are moving around
Mark: well too bad for them! They shouldn't have been moving cuz I've got the THUNDER!
Mark: WHOOOOOOO
uh oh... that's not good
*Mark shrieks*
Together: Awwwwww ha
Mark: Alright no more Hail Mary
Tyler: you had four guys I had two. I was like "Noo!"
Mark: It could've happened but my guys, they're just not the Patriots ya know?
If you just put clones of Tom Brady everywhere
*Mark shrivels under Tyler's intense glare* the world would be so
Mark: oh my god! sorry. (laughs)
Tyler: No! no.
Mark: Alright no- no more hail marys, let's- let's- let's- let's- let's- get real on this.
Tyler: You need to actually try and win this game
Mark: I'll try. I'll try.
Tyler: Hi!
Mark: Whoa! whoa--eeeeeeh--aggressive aaaawwwwwhhh
Tyler: Whoa!
Mark: aaarrgghh
Tyler: whoa!
Mark: He had that!
Tyler: He had it and the other guy was like
Mark: awhhhhh
Tyler: was like, he was like boop-no you don't!
Mark: booop, argghh he booped me!
he booped real g- alright you know what
time it is for?
Tyler: oh no...
Mark: yep!
Tyler: is it really?
Mark: yeaahhh (giggly)
Tyler: Back to your normal strategy?
Mark: Wh- it's the best strategy
what are you talking about normal?
It's every coach in football knows
like pfff- what ever- like- che- eugh- whatever
you know this, to be true
euuueughhg (weird Mark sound)
Tyler: gotta split it
Mark: goodbye
Tyler: you just keep running backwards
Mark: goodbye. goodbye. goodbye.
Tyler: What are you doing?!
Mark: I don't know!
Tyler Oh No!
Mark: aaagghhh!
Tyler: Is it gonna work?!
Mark: get it!!! get it!!!
Tyler: it freakin' worked!!
Mark: oooooohhhhh!!!
Whooaa!!! Hey! Ho! Hey! Hoooooo! Hoooo! (begins giggling)
Tyler: You ran all  the way to your own goal line and you "HAAABOOSKI"
Mark: HABOOSKI
Mark: That's the Markiplier way.Just habooski it into the- Into the endzone zone.
Tyler: That's just ridiculous!
Mark: I'm gonna do it again. *giggling*
Tyler: You know what? I'm not going to let you do it again
Mark: Oh Oh, Uh Oh, THATS NOT WHAT I WANTED
Mark: AHHHH NOOOO
Mark: Ahhh noooo
Tyler: I- I- I DB striked it
Tyler: Here we go
Both:AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!
Mark: Whoa I- I-
Tyler: That was my- I stole your dive tactic
Mark: I- I was so bad about like, I spammed circle, I just flipped between every character. It's the worst habit
Mark: Why do I want to spam circle?
Tyler: Hail Mary again
ugh!
Tyler: Here comes the Hail Mary tactic
Mark: (laughs)
Mark: Got you
Mark: (Grunting)
Tyler: Nope!
Mark: Ah so close
Mark: (random noises)
Mark: Man, Tom Brady, not only does he have arms of coiled steel,
but legs like a- like a-
Tyler: No! Imma- you know what-
Mark: Like a gazelle going through the prairie
Tyler: You know what I have an idea.
Mark: No, are you subbing in?
Tyler: I'm taking Tom Brady out!
Mark: No, no, no, no, no, no dude you can't do that! No, no, no, you have to be Tom Brady.
Mark: That's how it's gonna be in the Super Bowl
Mark: You HAVE to be Tom Brady.
Mark: This is legitimately the Super Bowl.
Tyler: Not if he gets hurt.
Mark: Well he's not gonna.
Mark: His defense is too good.
Mark: You've got eight seconds, you've gotta hurry
Tyler: AAH!
Tyler: I don't know what I called
Mark: Yeah I'm going, I'm going
Mark: Whatever it is, Go! Pull, Do it! Do the Thing!
Tyler: *grunting noises*
Mark: Hit it! GO! GO! GO! GO!
Tyler: I'm doing it! Nobody's there! Nobody's there!
Mark: okay
Tyler: what did I get it off?
Tyler: OOOOOO
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: *high pitched scream*
Tyler: NOO!
Mark: YESS!
Mark: YESSS!!!
*Tyler chokes*
Mark: I- WOAH
*Tyler laughs*
Tyler: I'm good
Mark: You alright there?
Alright
*Mark laughs in glee*
Tyler: My mo- my bleh bleh
Tyler: My throat got really scratchy
*Mark mimics Tyler*
Mark: I gotcha
Tyler: Oh no
Mark: Whatever it is...
Tyler: Do you-?
Tyler: Do you just go the suggestion and just scroll as fast as you can and hit x?
Mark:Yeah
Mark: What else would I do? *laughs*
Tyler: Then you don't know where your guys are going-
Mark: I don't care!
I don't care!
I don't care, I don't care, I don't care!
Cause it's AALWAYS GOOD!
*Mark makes pained grunting sounds*
Tyler: Woo
Mark: Oh man, his legs
Tyler: Woooah
*Mark laughs*
Tyler: That was like the glue: "I'm breaking!"
Mark: I'm fa- I've fallen apart, master
*Tyler giggles*
Mark: Put me back together again
Mark: I got this!
Matt Ryan's gonna deliver!
Mark: Gold!
Tyler: Nope nope nope
Mark: GOLD!
GOOLD!
YEAAAHHH!!
I did it!
*Tyler blubbers in disbelief*
Mark: I got-
*Tyler grunts and throws a mock punch*
*Both laugh*
Mark: Ow!
Mah sensitive underbelly!
Tyler: Just- just channeling the inner patriots.
*Mark laughs*
Mark: Got it! Stab!
Noh noh noh!
Tyler: I was just punching, you took it to next level
*Mark laughs*
Mark: Well, I'm just saying, you know, that's what the patriots do
OH so precise!
Look at this shit!
Look at that
Oh! *kisses fingers* Ah!
Eh! *makes sucking noises*
*Kisses fingers* Spicy!
UH! *kisses fingers again* Ah, good.
Tyler: I hate you
*Both burst out laughing*
Mark: Ooh, what a delicious kick!
Tyler: MMMM
Mark: I'm coming for-
Mark: Keys is coming
Tyler in goofy voice: Yuuh I'm goin' this way
Tyler: Oh, no I'm not! I lied.
Mark: KEY LIME PIE!!
Mark: Fuuu-*laughs*
*Tyler giggles
Mark: Just, like, I like to think the guy's:
"Key lime pie! I'm gonna, when this game over-"
Tyler: WOAAH!
*Mark makes kissy sounds*
Mark: Got the Key lime - UHOH!
*Both chuckle*
Mark: Whatever.
Tyler: HUT!
Tyler: I knew it!
Mark: NOOOO
Tyler: Run! Run! Run! Run!
Mark: No! No! No! No!
Tyler: I'm getting away from you!
Mark: TOM BRADY! *screams higher and higher*
Mark: TOM BRADY! TOM BRADY!
*Tyler screaming*
*Both screech*
*Tyler laughs hysterically while Mark chuckles*
Tyler: I like how you were chasing-
*Marks laugh drowns out words*
Tyler: You were like "NO Tom Brady, don't do it!"
Mark: I don't know anybody else on the team, so just...
Eh l-like, it's like the most fearful reaction
You just turn back to your native language:
"Tom Brady!" *pants* TOM BRADY, NO!
Anyone that sees Tom Brady - doesn't matter the gender-
They see him? Orgasm, right in their pants.
NOOOO!
*sounds of loss*
Tyler: I don't remember which one it was.
Mark: Oh yeah?
Mark: Two can play at that game!
Tyler: WOOH!
Mark: NO!
Mark: *disappointed* Awwww
Tyler: I..."blounted" right in there.
Mark: What does that mean?
Tyler: That's the guy's name
Mark:Oohh
I get it, it's a pun.
Tyler: Woah
Mark: Look at the spin move on this bad boy!
Both: WOOAH
Tyler: You juked me good
Mark: I know, right?
Tyler: I went "hoo!" And you were like "HOOO!"
Mark: I know
Mark "Hoo", I started flying in midair
What do you think of that, and hopefully...
Get some of-
Both: WOAH
Mark: I didn't know this was a run play
Tyler: OH NO
Mark: OHHHHHH
Mark squeals: NOOO!
*Both scream*
Tyler: You tricked me twice!
Mark: I didn't know what I did
*Tyler giggles*
Tyler: Like when you just spam circle?
Mark: I didn't even know it was a run play!
Tyler: Were you running backwards?
Mark:Yeah!
Mark: I thought I was a quarterback, I was like:
"Gotta back pedal this one!" *giggles*
Mark:Oops *in silly voice*
Mark:This is exactly how the Super Bowl is gonna go by the way
Mark: In case you all have forgotten
Tyler: They-their t-tricken
Mark: Yeah
Mark:T-Trick-Trickery
Tyler: A lot of trickery
Tyler:Oh
Mark What?!?! *high pitched voice*
Tyler:You ran outta time
Mark: Awwww
Mark: Wait but I had to kick off to you last ti-
*Tyler interrupts* No I kicked o- that wa- that was... *struggles for words*
Mark: *high pitched* What? *Mark groans* This doesn't make any sense...
Tyler: That was a, like, legit perfect kick.
Mark: Thank you. Tyler: I'm highly impressed. Mark: Thank you.
Mark: I AM PEEVED AND PISSED!
Mark: And by Tom Brady's epic thighs, I will get revenge.
Mark: Seems like he has the strongest thighs known to man..
Tyler: NO!! Mark: Aha! Where's your thighs now Brady? *jokingly*
Mark: Where's your thighs NOW?!?! *both giggle*
Mark: Bennett come back!
*Mark and Tyler break out in song* You can blame it all, on me!
Mark: Fuckin' Brady! Fuckin' Brady! Brady! BRADY! BRADY! Brady!
Mark: Brady... Tyler: I'm punting it- Mark:OH! Are you though?
Mark: Is it?  Tyler: This is the first punt of the game.
Mark: Really? Man everything else has been complete bullshit so, 'bout time we did something by the book.
Mark: No IDEA!! Oh god.. BE AGGRESSIVE!
Tyler: NO! Mark: *screech* oOOOOHH COME OOON!
Tyler: It was just like- Mark: *groans* Tyler: -and there was a boomp! Mark: Nooo...
Mark: How did that happen!?
Mark: PUNT? More like... opportunity for..... *quietly* sbunt..
*Mark giggles at his unfunny joke while Tyler smiles sympathetically*
Mark: Wait... hAHA! FAKING! Oh I'm fourth in inches?
Tyler: Yea. Mark: Wait- Tyler: You can just like run it up the middle.
Tyler: Oh you have ten seconds you might want to call a timeout. Mark: *talking over him* I got it.
Mark: No I got it. *starts grunting*
Tyler: Are you going to get the snapoff?
Mark: gAAAAHHHH
Mark: AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHH
Mark: GO FOR IT!
Mark: AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH! Tyler: No! NO! Mark: Yes! YES! YES! YES! YES! YES!
Mark: HE'S SO FAST! (x2)
Mark: OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHH
Tyler: 4th in inches and you score a touchdown? (Mark): OOOHHH I should run more (laughs)
Tyler: How many run-You've done like one run (Mark): I've done one (Tyler): NO there's (Mark): Was there?
Oh JESUS
(tyler): Going backwards and like "Wait I'm running!"
Mark: It's a tie game
Mark: Oh God NO GOD NO
Mark: GOD NO
Mark: GOD WHY
Mark: TOM BRADY
Mark: BRADY! BRADY! BRADY! Tyler: WOO!
Mark: what the f*ck was that?! *Mark laughing hysterically*  Tyler: I'm a rocket dude!
Mark: What was that? Tyler: He rocket shipped it.
Tyler: If you dive when you get close, he does a celebratory dive into the end zone.
Tyler: and I just.. *together* WOOOOOOOOOOO
Tyler: ROCKETSHIP!
Mark: It makes it all worth it, you know, it's okay, you can, you can have that touchdown, that's good.
Tyler: That was Hulk Hogan, too.
Tyler: You essentially can get, removed eligibility.
*Together* Whoooooaaaaa Tyler: HOLY COW!
Mark: WOOOAHHHH
Tyler: That's Julio Jones, he is one of the top receivers in the NFL.
Mark: Oh.
Mark: Should I have been throwing to him the whole time then?
Tyler: You have thrown to him a lot. Mark: Oh. Okay.
Mark: Tom Brady's gonna watch, THIS?! Really?
Mark: Awww JULIO, NOOOOOOOOHOHOHOOOOO! NOOOOOOOOO!
Tyler: I'm just- I was just sitting in the air
Tyler: There were three guys around there. Mark: Eeewwwww.
Mark: Still, it was Julio Jones-
You, you tricked me,
Julio Jones isn't as good as you said he was!
Mark: HERE COMES MY SEAM
Mark: HERE COMES MY SEAM!
Tyler: No!
Mark: What am I d-
Mark: Oh JESUS
Tyler: RUN BRADY!
Mark: Oh JESUS Christ
Mark: I was doing it again!
*Tyler laughs at Mark's failure*
Mark: AGH!
Tyler: NO! Nononono!
Tyler: Dammit!
Tyler: I gave him--Brady a Russian touch down!
Mark: He's just too good!
Tyler: NO!
Mark: NO ONE CAN STOP THE MAN!
Tyler: Is there not an undo?
Mark: What the f*ck was that?
Mark:I was--
Tyler: Oh!
Mark: I was that guy!
Mark: I should just not press buttons
Because I am-I am causing my own demise here
Tyler: I'm gonna do goal line
Mark: Nonono, don't make it easy on me!
Mark: Don't make it easy on me!
Tyler: Okay, fine!
Mark: Don't make it easy
Tyler: I won't make it easy on you
Mark: You think I need your-
Mark: You think I need your f-CHARITY, MR. BRADY?
Mark: As charitable a guy as you are, and you're..THE BEST
Mark: Don't think I need it!
Tyler: The old goal block
Mark: oh-? WHAT! NO! GODDAMMIT!
Mark: OH! F*CK!!
*Mark groans*
Mark: Don't time-out on me!
Mark: I don't want a time-out!
Mark: I want a crash and *giggles* burn!
Mark: I want a.
..fail miserably!
Mark: Dude, I got it!
Tyler: Do you?
Mark: I got it!
Tyler: OH NO YOU DO!!
*Mark adds his own sound effects*
Tyler: Nope, I want this guy
Mark: CHOOOOOM
*Laughter*
Tyler: It does it anyway!
Tyler: You rocket ship, too!
Mark: It's so cool!
Mark: Wheee!
Mark *mutters*: What the f*ck is with that camera?
Tyler: I dunno, it's like--
Tyler: What's in the face mask??
Mark: What's up your nose??
Mark: Are you hiding deflated footballs up your nose?
Mark: Hey! I did it!
Tyler: You did it!
Tyler: Now you need to get an on-side kick because you're down seven
Mark: OH! I have a chance?!
Tyler: Yes
Mark: REALLY?!
Mark: WHAT?!
Mark: Thank you!
Mark: uhh no, it didn't--
Mark: NOOOOOOO!
Mark: NO! DIVE! DIVE!
Mark: NOO! F*CK!!
Tyler: I-- *laughs*
Tyler: Did you see my thing?
Tyler: I did a rocketship!
Mark: Oh man
Mark: That was just--I panic
Mark: I panic every time
Mark: Every time I panic
Mark: I just dove in wrong directions!
Tyler: Your kicker dove, like *SCREAMING*
Mark: Here comes Poole!
*shriek*
Mark: Oh f*ck
Tyler: *laughing*
Mark: *cries out*
Mark: I'm so bad!
Mark: JONES!
Mark: Save me, Jones!
Mark: *screams*
Mark: WOAH
*both laughing*
Tyler: I would've laughed if you stopped!
Tyler: At like the one-inch line
Mark: OH MY GOD
Mark: Oh f*ck dude
Mark: But yay! The patriots have won!
Tyler: NO!
Mark: Tom Brady
Mark: Tom Brady has led his team to victory!
Mark: And with that, it's a decisive--
Tyler: Tyler wins, which means Tyler's team wins, which--
Mark: Wait, if you rearrange the letters of Tyler...
Mark: TOM BRADY
Tyler: NO!!
Mark: Congratulations Tom Brady!
Mark: Congratula--
Mark: Hey, be a good sport now!
Tyler: No, I'm a Patriot, I don't do that
Mark: That's a bit judgmental!
Mark: Be a good sport Tom Brady!
Mark: There we go!
Mark: AH! He deflated my hand!
Mark: That was our special football superbowl episode of whatever-the-heck-we're-doing-here, it was a lot of fun
Mark: Obviously, I wasn't gonna win
Mark: Because he knows like..the PLAYS
I don't even know how to press the right button
But I did pretty good!
Tyler: You did dang good!
Mark: I did surprisingly okay for what I was doing
Tyler *scoffs*: Yeah
Tyler: Spam means circles and switch players the whole time!
Mark: Apparently that's a good way to get half the points!
Mark: Anyway
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Thanks Tyler for joining me, this was a lot of FUN
Hope you guys enjoyed it, if you got a super bowl party, have fun with that
If you're not...remotely caring about the superbowl...
Hey, have a good Sunday!
Thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always...we will see YOU
In the next video!
Mark: BUH-BYE!